so starting with that breaking news out
of the United States a woman accused of
procuring underage girls for the
convicted sex offender Jeffrey Epstein
has herself now been arrested by the FBI
the British socialite ghilane Maxwell is
accused by multiple women of recruiting
them for Epstein and his friends to
abuse Jeffrey Epstein
you remember took his own life in prison
while awaiting trial in August of last
year more details now with Gabriel
Elizondo who's following the story from
New York Gabriel
yes we're being told that d'Alene
Maxwell was arrested in New Hampshire
which is a state just north of New York
City early this morning on this Thursday
morning she has in custody by the FBI
and were expected to hear more from
Southern District of New York
prosecutors here within the next hour or
so the u.s. is unsealed the indictment
against Maxwell and Maxwell is charged
in a six count indictment among other
things she is charged with conspiracy to
entice minors to travel to engage in
illegal sex acts among other things
Maxwell was a longtime a close confident
of the now-deceased
disgraced financier Jeffrey Epstein who
took his own life in a New York prison
last August while he was waiting trial
in federal sex trafficking charges
Maxwell was a longtime associate of him
and she had been pretty much missing for
several several months not seen anywhere
investigators in many countries had been
looking for her trying to find her but
clearly the FBI was able to locate her
and arrest her it's important to point
out that this case does have
international ramification because it
beats all the way to many different
countries because of the circles that
that Amin and Maxwell traveled in of
course all the way to the United Kingdom
where where Prince Prince Andrew has
been accused and he denies any
association but he has been accused of
being part of the
associate of epstein as well so you
pointed out that Gillian Murtagh has
been laying pretty low for the last well
almost a year I guess since Jeffrey
Epstein took his own life in prison is
that to say that the story went away for
a while or is this maintained its
momentum in the United States even with
everything else that's going along it's
gone away for a while quite frankly with
everything going on in the United States
especially in the last six months or so
with the other presidential election
with coronavirus the last six months or
so five or six months we have not heard
a lot about elane Maxwell quite frankly
and since Jeffrey Epstein did take his
own life
hung himself apparently in a prison in a
jail awaiting trial last August there
has not been a lot about this in the
u.s. in the last few months so law
enforcement officials perhaps maybe
seized on that to track her down but she
clearly has not made any public
appearances or as you mentioned almost a
year now so this arrest of her certainly
came as a big surprise no one was quite
expecting it okay so Gabriel Olin
Elizondo with that breaking news out of
the United States the arrest of ghilane
Maxwell by the FBI the longtime
confident of convicted sex offender
Jeffrey Epstein